so we're all going to die right now
we're ins
[Applause]
solti we're all on the floor we're all
going to
die what is
happening what are you doing take photos
I'm filming it are you outside so you
can get down I don't want to die I'll go
outside will you serious yeah do
it
[Applause]
holy
[__] what's Happ they told me they
yelled at me to get inside with Thea
it's okay that's great footage wait what
happened I don't know they just yelled
at it to get inside why was everybody on
the why was everybody on the ground I
don't know I think we're just freaking
out
on the ground can we reenact
that oh
[__] guys what's happening over here
we're not sure but I just Dove on the
ground
[Applause]
I I on the ground no I not going outside
or die no
crazy
[Applause]
W here wait
take here here do whatever you need to
do
one two three four five six seven police
cars Seven Police cars can you see that
[Applause]
yeah holy [__] that's the wrong invite
him in for a drink he deserves hell yeah
who the driver or the cop the driver
yeah did you [__] that's
crazy I bet it was the wrong guy it's
got to be the wrong guy the wrong
car he had like four or five guns pull
on dude [__] hey good for you guys hey
hey come have a drink with come have a
drink man we'll [__] pay for
it holy [__]
man okay wait wait wait is it still what
happened what happened they just let him
go they just put him back in the car and
they said uh sorry you guys are the
wrong people that's amazing thank
you so okay all right all right so we're
sitting here eating some delicious food
we see lights flashing and we all dive
on the
floor for no reason there's like guns
with with gun TOS with guns just like
standing out there pointing at the
corner of the restaurant and we're like
um is there a firefight about happen
here because I don't want to be like an
anent bystander you know I don't want to
be that guy oh my gosh I'm like so
nervous right now well and the best part
was like the people go out and they're
like what the hell and we should just
see them back up and then suddenly
they're like walking back I don't know
man the no like the girlfriend came out
of the car and totally was like that's
not or something cuz she was in the car
time she came out and like this
him yeah that was a little
int all he heard was all he heard was
get on the floor like oh [__] what's
going on oh my God and I look around the
restaurant everyone's on the floor and
then some guys yelling get up you idiots
get up get up which that it's that guy
over there so naturally I'm like get my
camera
well he's okay being the innocent
bystander that get job I
guess wow all right um just something
how do you feel a little traumatized my
heart's beating just a little bit yeah
yeah how about you I want to run out of
the room right now I'm so freaking out
how about you I know I just can't
believe what happen so crazy yeah not
every day that you have six seven police
cars come out and like a gun pulled out
your face that's what twice that
happened today I was on ter there's a
whole group of cops walking down ter I
kind of bummed out I got on the floor
and there's like no fireing no
shooting and all I was thinking is where
the hell is my
camera where where where and I was so
upset because my quick is my Nokia is
dead so I couldn't stream it
live the fix this and
post bye